cette décision historique en tunisie
deux mois après le limogeage du
gouvernement le président quelle side
vient de désigner une femme au poste de
premier ministre son nom najlae bouden
elle est chargée de former dans les plus
brefs délais un nouveau gouvernement et
direction tunis où l'on retrouve notre
correspondant sur place ben hassen
chébili
bassem bonjour c'est donc une première
dans le pays
bonjour doral effectivement c'est une
première et une annonce plutôt
exceptionnelle qui a été fait il ya à
peine un peu moins d'une heure par le
chef de l'état par communiqué qui a été
diffusé sur le site de la présidence de
carthage après deux mois d'attentes deux
mois de crise politique deux mois deux
gouvernements deux ministères
complètement à l'arrêt sans parler du
parlement qui est toujours fermé le
président de la république est sorti de
son silence et a enfin désigné le nom du
nouveau chef du gouvernement c'est une
femme plusieurs personnes parler déjà de
l'hypothèse que kaïs saïd puis se mettre
une femme à la tête du gouvernement elle
ce qui représente une première dans
l'histoire politique de la tunisie majda
bouden elle va être chargé dans les plus
brefs délais de former un gouvernement
un cabinet comme l'a annoncé la
présidence de la république elle est née
en 1958 à la 63 ans est une
intellectuelle au maintien junior de
formation en géologie elle a été
diplômée elle des mines à paris elle
originaire de kerran une ville au centre
du pays elle a été plusieurs fois
les occupé plusieurs postes dans les
précédents à un gouvernement depuis 2015
mais des postes qui étaient consacrées
notamment sur l'éducation elle était
chargée de mission auprès du cabinet du
ministre de l'enseignement super de la
recherche scientifique elle a aussi
travaillé comme directrice générale
chargée de la qualité au ministère de
l'enseignement après des mois de crise
et de gel en tunisie cette annonce est
vécue par les tunisiens comme un réel
soulagement comme peut-être l'espoir de
sortir de cette crise politique qui
vraiment gangrène le pays depuis des
mois et des mois sans parler de
l'impatience de la société civile outils
et d'épée des partis politiques
d'opposition qui ont demandé au chef de
l'état de pouvoir accélérer un peu le
processus et surtout de revenir sur
cette décision d'abroger une partie de
la constitution lui reprochaient
notamment de gouverner seul à ne pas 30
repart ou discussions notamment avec les
forces dites politiques dans le pays
cette nomination arrive vraiment un bon
moment peut-être que ça va décanter un
petit peu crise de politique en tunisie
de rouvrir le dialogue entre les partis
politiques et qui le gouvernement et le
chef de l'état en attendant cette
décision comme je voulais dit doha est
intervenue il ya un peu moins d'une
heure et on attend encore plus
d'informations de la part de la
présidence de carthage concernant cette
nouvelle nomination plus tôt historique
en tunisie tels de madame neiges de
google nouveau chef du gouvernement en
tunisie merci beaucoup bassem chab et
pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouvera bien évidemment dans nos
prochaines éditions pour donc suivre de
près ce qui se passe actuellement en
tunisie